l'itinéraire temps maussade roger perron
c'est ce sera plus difficile de
convaincre les passants de sortir 3 $ de
leur poche
il touche 1 dollar 50 pour chaque
exemplaire vendu
c'est un ami qui lui avait parlé de
l'itinéraire des difficultés financières
l'aide sociale et to him the bay levant
le journal se pareront tire un peu des
fins de mois
alors si simplement comme ça que ça a
commencé mais c'est beaucoup plus pour
cet homme qui a déjà écrit des articles
sur le sport et les loisirs
si ce qui est amusant c'est qu'on n'a
pas de spécialité comme tel j'ai eu
l'occasion de faire une autre vie que le
général dallaire qui était au rwanda
j'ai déjà écrit des articles sur les
musées que j'ai parlé de pops
l'itinéraire ses douze mille exemplaires
toutes les deux semaines
quinze employés dont six à la rédaction
une vingtaine de bénévoles et 150
camelot entre 40 2 50 % de contenu du
magazine est assurée par les camelots
qui sont accompagnés dans leur dans la
rédaction dans les entrevues qui font
avec des personnalités la salle de
rédaction du deuxième étage reçoit des
invités comme la comédienne gabrielle
marion riba
on est bien loin des feuillets
photocopier des premiers numéros un
stagiaire en travail social qui
travaillait pour un centre que yeux fous
projette de faire écrire des personnes
en situation d'itinérance
plusieurs de nos articles sont repris
aujourd'hui des articles de l'itinéraire
sont traduits en anglais ou en allemand
pour d'autres journaux de rue à l'heure
où les journaux vont vers les
plateformes numériques
l'itinéraire lui existe pour ces
camelots on est un média avec une
mission est donc un le camelot avec son
journal en mai et dans la rue il ya déjà
qu'ils s'arrêtent qui parle avec eux en
cinq six ans était arrivé une fois ou
deux des gens d un peu peur en dribble
je m'excuse je tenterai notarié
à noël on a augmenté le tirage de 3000
copies en irak 15000 et puis c'est parti
dans une semaine à la merci ginette reno
le journal s'offre un nouveau logo pour
ses 25 ans et c'est la députée catherine
dorion qui fera la première page du
prochain numéro
ici à nourrice despatie radio canada
montréal